we're ready right yes so hi I'm Robert
Verdi I'm going to talk a bit about the
basic a line system house looks inside
some of the a bit of history showing he
took try and explain why it looks like
it does as well yeah I come well I
originally was part of the the
corralling team so we were three of us
was John strong Mike Williams and myself
who the basic designers of the original
language more people came in later of
course currently I work for our Lang
solutions and we do consulting training
support in and around our lang and
Alexia systems and we have officers a
bit everywhere so yeah this is the
outline will end up in the somewhere in
the middle trying to explain what the
what the ecosystem means and how we view
it and how can be extended with things
like this and we build time we have some
examples showing some ideas as if this
work tell me yes right okay not much
here so there are a couple of points I
want to make which if you go out you'll
sometimes see these taken up and
mentioned so yes our line was developed
by Ericsson so when we were developing
we were working for Ericsson however no
it is not a telecom language a lot of
times you'll read people saying is
uninteresting versus telecom language
it's not a telecom language and I like
to try and explain why it isn't and what
and what what it is right so a little
bit of history trying to just describe
it there's a reason for the way it looks
like it does and originally we're now
talking in the 80s Ericsson had the
product called the ax e was a telephone
exchange switches and was a very
successful product but it required quite
a lot of work to develop and maintain
the software and I was working in a
computer lab at that time that Ericsson
had and one of the things we're trying
to look at is how we could improve the
system making it easier to program and
maintain it that was what we're looking
at other things as well
but this is one of the things we're
looking at but the important thing was
had to have the same characteristics
okay I don't think they intended us to
make a new language but that's where we
ended up so what we found out here is
that if you look at this problem the
problem domain we were looking at the
telecoms part was not difficult
I mean controlling the switch someone
had already written that we didn't have
to worry about controlling the switch
and getting information from the switch
he send a command to the switch and it
does it you connect people together it
send another command as phones start
ringing all that work had been done for
us that was that was that the problem
the same thing getting information from
the switch that was quite easy to fix so
we get into that information into the
system so what was the problem and the
these are some of the main issues once
we're tackling was that you had to be
able to handle a lot of concurrent
activities going on so in those days a
big switch might have a few hundred
thousand lines coming in you might have
tens of thousands of calls going on at
the same time plus all the things that
switch is doing and you have to be able
to handle all these at the same time
there are timing constraints things have
to happen at a certain time or within a
certain time and that means the system
can never block whatever happens if
something is something supposed to
happen a specific time it must happen at
that time whatever the system is doing
it cannot block you need distribution if
you want to build a fault
extremely a seriously fault-tolerant
system you need multiple machines if we
need some form as helpful distribution
another feature here is that it has to
be in continuous operation over many
years this was talking back in those
days to switch to start the switch off
it it's supposed to run for years right
even if you're doing software
maintenance so if you're doing upgrading
the system the switch must not go down
while you're doing this for and there
are strict requirements for fault
tolerance so when things go wrong in
hardware or you get some programming
errors the switch must not go down yes
you could lose a few calls but the
switch is
must never go down and the interesting
thing is if you look at these none of
these have anything telecom specific
this describes the problem we were
trying to solve and it's not it wasn't a
telecom problem is that you took us a
while to realize that this wasn't just
telecoms I can still say the first time
I heard someone written a web server an
hour long I thought why would anyone
want to write a web server an hour long
right and if you go back and reflect on
it you can say that's a very good choice
just what was more powerful so yeah so
the ally in the system around it was
designed to solve this type of problem
and there's direct support an hour-long
an OTP
for supporting these issues that's what
it's all about
it's concurrent fault-tolerant scalable
systems basically some more reflections
here we weren't out to make a functional
language
it became functional along the way
because we thought this we felt as we're
going this was a very good choice for it
we weren't out to implement the actor
model we read later in papers saying
Elling implemented the actor model we
had never heard of the actor model we
just arrived at this type of idea as
very suitable for what we wanted it to
do right so yeah we were trying to solve
the problem the whole development of the
Erlang language and the system around it
was very problem oriented we had a
problem solve it this meant development
the language system was very focused we
had a clear set of criteria for the
language and the system should do the
six points I mentioned there if we could
not do that it wasn't interesting no
matter how fantastic it was we just had
to solve that problem and that meant the
language in the system evolved to solve
this problem so we were very fortunate
we had a user group who'd come back from
they were from the system side and they
can come back with comments on our ideas
and how on the language and how the
language should be used they could come
back and say this was a good idea this
didn't work or whatever and sometimes we
just made wrong suggestion choices so
where do we end up
like wait concurrency concurrency is
very fundamental property must be able
to handle a lot of processes there must
be cheap in every way asynchronous
communication
if you have time at the end I'll show
you the way should not have synchronous
communication in parallel systems it
takes about three minutes process
isolation and the error handling so when
something goes wrong in a process
crashes it should be isolated you
shouldn't ruin things for other
processes we need support for error
handling for making error handling
systems so we've felt that things like
in currency and error handling were so
fundamental to the problem this is not
something you put in afterwards as a
library this is something you build into
the base system the primitives for
continuous evolution the system we need
to be able to upgrade the system while
it's running load code in running
systems and not crash the system while
you're doing it and it's soft real-time
so we had these timing constraints if
you sometimes miss one it wasn't too bad
it wasn't hard real time real real time
people say it's not real time but we
call it soft real time but it means the
system must never block ok you can't sit
and wait for 5 or 10 seconds while it's
garbage collecting that's just not
allowed a few other things we wanted a
higher level language okay this was late
80s so things weren't that high at that
time
yeah like compared to the Lillet systems
there was we wanted the language and the
system to be simple simple in the sense
that you have a basic simple number of
base small number basic principles and
on top of that you can build anything
you want ok that is difficult time small
is good in this case and I know that see
if I get the right here some victors
have some very nice quotes about this
and he says simplicity is a great virtue
that requires hard work to achieve it in
education to appreciate it and to make
matters worse complex yourselves better
and it's quite true there it is
difficult to make a simple system you
get the right basics it's very easy to
make a complex system you need something
you just chuck it in enough while your
system grows in complexity get the basic
stuff right is difficult
we also found provide tools not
solutions we tried to provide solutions
but we usually got them wrong and then
they come back and so know that we can't
use this anyway so the basic idea is
provide tools and then lift the users
build the solutions they need so yeah
that that's that's actually not me
playing that's me working all right so
this was in 91 there was a trade show
and we're going to demo Erlang and we
wanted something to try and attract
people to it and we had a small switch
in the lab so all our experiments were
actually done against telecom systems
that is the switch and we felt that
showing that at the conference will not
attract anyone there are no blinking
lights or anything so we thought ok
would make a train set and we'll have
the train set control piling and which
we did this is me sitting experimenting
all the freely admit I went slightly
overboard here because we ended up with
automatic train control system so accept
racks multiple trains running good books
the track through the strange system and
everything and work and they wouldn't
crash or collide or anything like this
and it was fault tolerant as well - of
course
so yeah that's work so where we end up
with the language the sequential
language it's a simple functional
language it has a slightly different
syntax but most functional languages
have a different syntax it's got your
typical language functional features
it's immutable data immutable variables
extensive use of pattern matching
recursion rules these are just your
standard functional stuff it's
dynamically typed and there are no user
defined data types
I can discuss afterwards widened there I
use it for that so for the sequential
language is a pretty standard functional
language there's nothing strange about
it really then you get into the the
concurrency side for it we want a
lightweight isolated processes literally
millions of processes you can do that in
the Erlang system asynchronous message
passing that is the only safe way if you
want complete we're going to guaranty
non-blocking systems if you put
synchronous communication there
eventually you're screwed
they'll be very cheap we have a
selective receive mechanism which allows
you to say which messages are interested
in receiving now and just leave all the
other ones for
later and we don't do global data so
that's the concurrency that's the basic
premises of the concurrency now for
error handling the basic thing is errors
will always occur get over and build a
system that can handle it and what we
want to do in the basic goals here is
the system must never go down so yes you
might get errors going in the system but
the system must be able to detect those
errors recover and keep on going
it should never crash right but we want
to avoid writing error checking code
everywhere if you've ever done this
you'll thought you'll know what a pain
it is now easily is to get it wrong
right so we just want to let this let it
crash right so something goes wrong in a
process let that process crash someone
else will detect it and know what to do
when that process does clean up after to
restart it which means that it's it's
very seldom you actually write error
handling code anywhere we can avoid
there are some cases you need to do it
but most of the case you can just
program as if everything worked when it
crashes someone else will clean up after
you it's like having enormous cleanup
team around you all the time right and
so what you need to build robust systems
will at least two things you need you
need to ensure that something that
necessary functionality is always
available if some pilot system you have
to have to be whether it works if it's
not their system is not up and you need
to clean up when things go wrong and
well you also need much least two
machines if you want to really fault
tolerance for Muni distribution for so
the first thing with the necessary
functionality is that's what we call
supervision trees that's that's the
method we use to do that in that you
have some processes which are
supervisors and their job is to monitor
other processes in this we have a
supervision tree here and we have this
supervisor monitoring this supervisor
and that process that worker process and
this supervisor monitoring those workers
and if a worker dies the supervisor
knows what to do its main job is to
restart things so this is how weakening
we can ensure that necessary
functionality is always there
if some critical server process dies it
will have a supervisor that restarts a
weekend thing and can continue right
that's all the supervisors do the other
thing of course is cleaning up we have
we need to be able to monitor processes
and when they die clean up after them
free resources or whatever it might be
for and also we can have groups of
cowork co-worker processes they are
linked together and if one dies they
will die basic rationale is they should
either all work will not want or they
all die for and the basic error handling
mechanisms do this for they use for
building this that they're not part of
the base system but they're the basic
tools for building these type of
functionality on top of the system so
you get it that leads us upwards so we
have the language here and when we're
developing the language we had ideas
about how we should use the features in
the language and we had the the the
requirements we had to push down into
the features so the features of the
language and how they we use a very very
work mesh together okay so we have the
concept safe for links and using a links
or supervisor could detect if it's if a
child process has died and restarted or
you could have a serve which could
monitor a processor using resources from
it and when they die clean up afterwards
using the same mechanisms for doing this
and OTP it's a set of design patterns
for building concurrent fault tolerant
systems yes there is a telecom whoops
one one sorry there is a telecom in the
word here but it's not a telecom
specific anyway if you look what's
actually there there's nothing telecom
specific in it the closest is an ASN dot
one compiler for interfaces that's about
it right but it's all based on the
original system ideas we had these ideas
and monitoring things for for restarting
for cleaning up and stuff like this for
it this is something called there's a
concept called generic behavior which
implements these design patterns and
there's also support for adding new
behaviors it's it's not a closed box
where you have this wealth of five basic
behaviors when you start
you can add new behaviors if you want
them as well - and there's a set of
rules for building behaviors and you
follow those rules they'll just fit in
it's quite simple actually it also
contains a large number of libraries and
support tools for building systems and
we what we call releases it's actually
quite simple once you get into it to be
honest yeah there is nothing about
telecom and OTP it's a very politically
politically correct name from coming
from a telecom company versus the same
thing and saying our legs not a telecom
language this is not a telecom system
and what you happen to find is that
systems built with our line tend to be
very operating system like in their
field they provide services for what you
want to do here and there is very seldom
any central thread of execution in these
systems again think an operating system
I'm doing lots of different stuff for an
operating system if I want a new browser
I just pop one up and I just run it and
keep on going I can take it down I can
start up new functionality and things
like this it's very much the same thing
in airline systems the closest you can
get having any central form of execution
central theory of execution is something
which starts tasks right so if you're
talking telecoms there will be a set of
processes there and every time a calls
made it will start a number of processes
for starting that call and those process
just go when keep executing when the
call goes the process of got go away if
you're thinking servers typically for
example you have a server running every
time a new connection comes up one part
start a few processes handling that
connection and that's all it does then
then those processes handle the
connection and when the connection goes
down there go away it's very seldom a
central thread of execution I tend to
think of it not so much as a language
with concurrency but more a system with
a language for building it's for
building the systems what we're really
all about here so that's looking from
the language upwards we now we can also
go downwards here and ask the question
what is the beam well that's very simple
it's a virtual machine to run a line
that says everything and it says nothing
what does all this mean one the beam is
actually stands for bog dance our line
abstract machine and bog done Houseman
he was a guy working with in the lab the
early 90s and he started doing well the
second virtual machine actually the
first one was called a gem which was
Joe's abstract machine and this beam has
now been modified and updated er for
about 25 years there's probably not much
of the original code there but still
called the beam B the B actually stand
for Buren alpha B on Gustav's on took
over mostly internal work for so what's
in what is this what's a virtual machine
to run a line and yeah well this looks
very familiar doesn't it so all the
properties in the language there's
direct support for all these in the in
the beam so its support for handling
lightweight massive concurrency and yes
I can say massive in this case I mean
having millions of processes is actually
perfectly feasible to do it there are
systems that do it as well to I mean
real live runtime systems that do it
it's based asynchronous communication if
you wanted a synchronous communication
you send one message and that's it and
the person you're requesting sends back
a reply and is didn't wait for it this
process Oaks a lot isolation built into
the system so if one a long process
crashes the others won't be affected
there is support for the error handling
the error handling primitives are
directly supported in the virtual
machine their support for the continued
evolution of the system there are
primitives for handling and reloading
code in the system while the system is
running it also means I can reload any
module wireless system is running and
that will never crash the system the
only of that module is in use I can
reload it the worst thing that can
happen some Erlang processes might die
but the Aling system as a whole will
never go down because of that
so it's just something I don't have to
worry about at that point there's soft
real-time there so the real-time hand
the time handling all the support for
that is in the virtual machine itself
but there's so the connection between
the beam and our line is very close
right it's it's a very much
a virtual machine for running Ally its
non-blocking it's blocking the system is
something I never have to worry about
I can send off a request to someone or
say no external system say the database
and just sit and wait there for seconds
and the system won't it never block like
it is practically impossible to block
the system again think an operating
system for a lot of loading might slow
it down but not blocking it for example
is a pre-emptive scheduler so even if
you have one process that's running
continually executing it will be
reschedule all the time the system just
does not block it's got transparent SMP
multi-core support so quite happily when
you start up barreling and will grab
every core confined it will use them all
and will load balanced automatically
across them that this is something I
just don't have to think about I have
control over it I can limit it but I
don't have to think about it and worry
about it there are a number of powerful
introspection and internal prep tracing
primitives for looking at the system
while the system is running I can show
have time I show some simple examples of
that but it's a very powerful system a
lots been put in to managing production
systems were in use so I can look
internally into the system and see
what's going on while it's running and
there are a number of interfaces the
outside world we'll talk more about
those later it's got the typical
functional stuff immutable data predicts
a predefined set of data types
there's patent matching this functional
language support the handling of modules
and code again is built into the virtual
machine and again the fact there's no
global data we just don't do global so
this gets us what - what the outline
ecosystem is so it's a set of languages
built and running on top of the beam
along an OTP
so we have this layer around here which
is the beam - everything runs on top of
the beam we had our line go TP support
and libraries for it and then we can
have a set of languages running on top
of those using those
our lang of course is there so we have
another one for example as Alex here
which is very good which is a very
growing language on top it's partly a
Pylea ecosystem we have LFE which stands
for list flavor darling for we who like
parentheses it's there there is also
there's a Prolog implementation and law
implementation other languages are well
all running on top of the ecosystem now
the thing here is that if these
implementations language implementations
follow the rules correctly they're all
interactable so they can interact with
each other and they can support each
other so I can I can in principle write
my application in different languages
and have them calling each other in the
right way just getting them working
together right so just because I pick
our line doesn't mean everything has to
be a line or just because I pick a
legacy everything doesn't have to be
Alex here I can mix these two quite
close together for it so yeah so now
we're getting beyond our line right so
now we want to extend the system so how
can we do that so what what we want to
provide is new skins the old ceremony we
have the our line at the bottom we've
got the beam we've got our line at the
bottom and the beam is can't stress it
is very a line specific for example it
just will not do mutable data this is
not the compiled our line compiler
saying you can't update something this
is the beam which does not update things
if you try and do it internally the
chances are it either won't work you're
crashing so you just adjust support for
it so it's new skins the old ceremony if
you have not heard this CD you should
it's a wonderful CD it's like what
everything Leonard Cohen is very
depressing but it's very good music and
I will not play it for you later yeah so
how does it work well as again we have
the beam here we have our language P so
my new language I'll implement this in
some way on top here and new language
libraries on top so that they'll both be
on top of our land on top of OTP and
using those
this is the basic way we extend the
system and it's like a skin and the
thickness of the skin will very much
affect how efficient it is and how it
works so sometimes it'll be very thin
skin sometimes be very thick skin it's
up to you to choose what you need and
we'll do thing for it so yeah so I would
say I class they're three different
classes of extending the system what one
I call native languages
these are languages basically keep the
Erlang execution model and data types
but just provide a new say a new syntax
and different packaging and things like
this for so this is definitely the most
efficient way of running a new language
on top of it because we're basically
running our Lang it look might look and
feel very different some examples of
this are Alexia which is a language has
grown quite quite a lot over the last
couple of years which looks very
different in many ways feels different
but it's the same thing we have LFE FN
is one that's sort of inspired by python
we have closure which is a closure like
language running on top and there also a
number of statically to experiments
doing statically typed languages so I
mentioned our line is done dynamically
typed and it only has to set a
predefined set of data types again this
is directly what support in the machine
there are reasons for this okay discuss
them later but that's just the way it is
so if we look here alexia well dynamic
functional language designed for
building scalable and maintainable
applications of course if you look at it
it's influenced by Ruby but it's
definitely not Ruby so if you look at
the syntax you've looked at Ruby you'll
find this click clear similarity between
the syntax and the alexia syntax has
many taken many features and Ruby syntax
but be very aware we are not running
Ruby because Ruby has a lot of things
that will just not run on the beam for
example mutable data
it has metaprogramming capabilities
using macros there's a macro package as
a macro system rather defined in the
language which allows you to write your
own macros and it takes down the
language a lot of the things you'll do
standard stuff you'll find an Alexia are
actually macros this is nothing strange
however you can't change the syntax
because the handling of macros is done
after you've passed it so what you write
in your file has to be possible by the
Alexia parser then you can macro then
you can do macro processing and change
that before goes into the compiler
now the Alexia syntax is pretty well
lacks in some way so you can write
things which actually are function calls
but don't look like function calls in
many of the standard things if I mean
that the syntax you use for defining a
function the death it does not look like
a functional call but syntactically it
actually is one and expands into a macro
so a lot of the system the macros a lot
of packages you'll find in Alexia will
have macro type interfaces we were
looking before the X unit to test the
unit test facility there you're writing
tests using macros it also comes with an
extensive set of build tools and
packages there are a lot of a lot of
packages that come with Alexia it's
being spent extended and from a very
early stage that I said a build tool for
building systems with it but at the
basic level it still has the same
semantics as early because that's what
the beam provides you which means it's
quite an easy to interface Alex you're
nailing because they're same basic data
types same operations anything like this
for me the other one which I like which
I've done is this play with a line it's
a lisp so it's a lisp syntax front-end
work it's a real lisp with all the real
lisp goodies so to proper her my iconic
language and with real this macros
macros the way god intended right the
macros to work and just effective for
but it's not scheme it's not common list
because these will not
as they stand on top of the a-line
system so the Lisp has been adapted to
fit onto the a-line system again this is
what you need to do so for example
there's no immutable data it's only the
standard airline data types it has our
Lang Stein style modules and functions
so if you've trying to look at it say
coming from so commonly spamming your
packages they just don't exist
Allen does not support the primitives
you need to build a package system for
that just not how it handles code
workout hounds atoms there and macros
only compile time because at runtime in
the Erlang system there are just
compiled functions there's no there's no
direct assist web de triomphe or example
what you need to do for those who know
Lisp is to Lisp to instead of a lisp one
if you don't know this doesn't make any
difference if you do I can gladly take
the argument afterwards but there's a
specific reason for doing this but again
this is another thing here as well for
yeah standard data types yes so a line
only has a predefined set of data types
and what you will the beam has a
predefined set of a little ten types
which means you can in principle not
define your own data types so what L
lang and Alexia do and Lily fee is one
they fake it so you make something that
looks like your own defined data type
but you actually implement using on to
running it on top of something else so
from the a line point of view they have
something that's called records which
gives you nice syntax you can define
records as certain operations on records
but they're implemented on top of the
standard tuples just using a tag couple
for Alexia has something called structs
which gives you the same features I can
define struct sucking you type checking
of at least access checking of structs
at runtime but they're just built on top
of maps and there's just no way around
this yeah I'm not I'm not going to talk
about a Fenian closure there for it but
this is something interesting as well so
as I've said number of times that there
is no static type system so the base
language
very system is dynamically-typed and
people feel would be very nice to have a
statically typed functional language
running on the online system and there
have been there is a number of well as
yet experiments doing this so one for
example is alpaca which is it statically
typed legally evaluated functional
programming language it relies on it
well it relies on type inference and all
the things you expect in it but at the
base level everything just compiles down
to a line it's ml inspired this means
that in the alpaca system itself when
the modules to find an alpaca I can I
can do type checking I can be very
certain that the type chat types are
checked and it is type correct this then
lope ins up a lot how actually want to
implement my user-defined types but in
in the in this site part of the system I
know I'm type safe which is very nice
however the problem is when I interact
with the rest of the world in this case
the rest of the ally insists the beam
system which is not type safe so there's
in in the a-line system there is nothing
stopping me calling any function I want
with any arguments and why default all
this checking is done at runtime which
is completely against what what we're
doing here and the same thing with when
processes are communicating I can send
any message to I want to any process the
system does not block and stop anything
like this which means if I'm doing
something like this I need some form of
shell around my my type statically type
check system interacting with the
outside world for but doing that then I
can I can build a system inside which I
know is type safe and as I said there's
not mount of work going on this alpaca
it sort of works but it's not production
ready there are some people doing F
sharp as well on it which would fit
quite well and again you have the same
problem there y'all can make my packages
work but I need to work this so this is
coming on you
it's interesting you'll be interesting
to see how when they get them better
further wrong and development how useful
they are and how they get them to
interact with the rest of the system so
I know there's quite a lot of interest
in this yeah
the next level is are you standing the
system like what I call non native
languages so now I want to run a
language I want to run languages on top
of the Erlang system but they're not
Elling like however look at it
alexia LFE well the other ones close
your app a cassette they are alum Erlang
like in their semantics I can change the
syntax I can add packaging systems and
do a lot of things for it but the base
level here's here we're looking at what
happens if I want to let implement a
language on top of the Erlang system
which has completely different semantics
and I have two examples here like if
these examples I've done them myself I
think they're probably others as well do
it and one news I want to run Lua or I
want to run Prolog on top of the system
here so what is lower
it's a powerful efficient lightweight
embeddable scripting language supports
procedural programming object-oriented
programming functional programming data
different programming and data
description it basically supports
everything right and it's quite actually
it's a quite a nice little language I'm
very impressed because they've managed
to keep the language simple and they
managed to get the right basic
primitives in and we're using these
primitives you can build a lot of stuff
on top of it yes I can make it
object-oriented it doesn't have a
concept of classes but using the tables
and meta tables I can implement
something like classes for it's a very
nice for simple little system and
Louella is an implementation of this
running in our lang which implements Lua
5.2 well it doesn't do the co-routines
that's about it right everything else it
does for and Lua
is very different amongst other thing it
has shared global mutable data defined
in the language right
how should work and without that it
wouldn't belong so if you're going to
implement law you have to do you have to
implement shared mutable global data
which airline doesn't support the lower
handling of code is completely different
so these are things there are other
features as well for it that you just
have to do yourself if you can do it if
you want to look and the goal here is to
make something that is compatible with
law not lower like or lower influence
but Lua
that's what Lu l is there are other
things as well in the language that just
don't fit again it's very nice to the
language they've also been vert they're
also very conservative in their
development so they've reached 5.2 now
that was a couple of years ago they went
to 5.3 and then they did something
extremely radical they added integers
before that all the numbers were
floating points and there was printed a
lot of argument about integers where
they should be they're not for kiss
which means it's very compatible so
how's it done right well this means I
have to implement a system on top which
interprets lower will compile or a
little bytecode or something like this
and manage the whole state myself so
what this is this is now this is the
airline data structure to record which
implements contains all the lower state
so it contains information for tables
the main data type will the only the
only structured data type you have in
lower our tables key value tables you
knew that you need you need frames
because the the call frame is immutable
so after you sometimes have to handle
those
I need the current global table the
bottom level global table whichever it
references everything I need to keep
track of the stack there are met all the
atomic data types have meta tables as
well so I've got a meta table for nil
for boolean's for numbers and for
strings so I need to carry these things
around with me as well for I need a
random state so each each implementation
Elul has its own random number
generation ports I don't overlap and
well I need a tag so I can crash it in
the right way
so so what you need to do here this this
case is lower but you do another
language have exactly the same problem I
need to manage a state containing all
the stuff that is not our Lang you and
carry that around with me and work on
that so if I'm adding a new table then I
add a table into this into the table
table here and if I'm updating a table
will I go in extract that table mutate
this which is just now long datatype
mutate it and put it back in again they
to carry all these things around with me
there are a few more for accessing
things and stuff like this and well too
but this is type of work I need to do if
I'm putting a language into like into
our language is not Allen another
example not gonna go deep into it is org
which is standard Prolog it's a subset
of Strix it's a strict subset of
standard Palo and again it's got
completely different semantics fella so
it's got backtracking logical variables
and unification which Alan doesn't have
so I have to do I have to do this myself
in the language itself in the
implementation fortunately most of the
mapping between analog and our line data
structures pretty straightforward except
for logical variables because they
update sometimes I bind them when I
backtrack them I lose bindings and
things like this for so this is two
examples if I wanted something like all
a non-native language the third level is
extending the system using external
systems accessing things on the outside
and there are a number of ways of doing
this there's the basic mechanism the
original one it's called ports and that
just allows me to talk to other
operating system processes by sending
messages to them so in the outline from
the other side I open a port and there's
an operating system process the other
end
I send bytes to it it will arrive there
when they send bites back also his
message coming from the external site
makes the outside world look like a
process in just any messages backwards
and forth that's a very nice way of
doing things
we have NIF's which are natively
implemented functions that's a way of
implementing functions in c and calling
them from our lang as if they are a long
defined functions so i can set up a
module accessing
thing outside and I'll call it from our
line functions and I'll do the outside
work there for example if you're running
say raspberry pi you can make it you can
make a set of NIF's
that implement the I squared C interface
then I can talk I squared C from my
raspberry pi the outside doing this by
calling our line functions there's a set
of libraries for converting to and from
our line data structures their support
for doing threads as well there so I can
start up threads from magnificent run
things for they use quite a lot today we
also something called C nodes which is
in between its it's a way of writing
having an another operating system
process written in another language but
from the outlying point of view it looks
like a distributed airline node so I can
link to or I can send messages to it and
things like this for as well there's a
bit of work needed to do it to make it
behave properly
but there's support for doing that and I
can talk with other languages as well I
think rust and wear of assembly of
things are probably arriving the neuf
interface allows me to talk to anything
just as long as I go through a see
function an example of a seat well
examples of C nodes here the J interface
that's something that comes with a
standard a standard outline release it's
a way of talking with Java it's
basically a set of Java class the size
where I can run Java I can send our
messages backwards and forth from it
peer laying is something a colleague did
of mine that's for doing the same thing
with Python so I can start a Python
machine other Python processes I can
talk backwards or forward from the
Python to it so you could use a line as
a interactive concurrent glue between
Python systems and sending messages
between them as well
yeah okay so why we have these three
basic three basic alternatives why would
I choose one over the other right so why
choose a native language well however
you look at it it's the optimal use of
the beam because you're doing what the
beam is meant to do and it's definitely
the fastest thing you can get running on
the beam however you look at it's
conceptually easy to interface because
it's just a line
and it's safe what I mean by safe here
is you make a mistake in that in the
crash at all you'll happen is your crash
now Lange process you will not crash the
yelling system we're something pretty
paranoid about safety but yes so it's
safe in that sense the downside of
course is you basically restricted
traveling like languages you cannot get
around that they may look and feel very
different if you look at Alexia it looks
very different in many ways it feels
very different but the base level is the
same that's just a limitation of it and
typically you probably a large
environment to do it anyway I mean you
want libraries you want tools you want
you probably want your own Ripple
something like this you want Lemax mode
of course they can you can edit the
language right but you need these things
for doing it
and if again if you go back the elixir
side you'll find they have this big
environment around the language so next
one of course is what happens to undo
not non-native languages the examples of
being lower land analog here well there
are no restrictions I can do whatever I
want I can make my language as global as
mutable they're shared whatever it's up
to me to implement it's a good use of
the beam in the sense I'm still running
inside beam processes that I can still
communicate with other things we're
written in other languages and on the
beam and directly just plus any data
across on calling functions I've got
fast data transfer with Alec because I'm
just running inside the outline system
all the time right and it's safe because
again I might have any I might have
written interpreter like the loyal
system that that interprets law but it's
running inside a normal hour long
process and if that crash is just just
as normal a line family photographer
the downside is that it is often slower
than doing a normal implementation I
take my language X and implement outside
in C or whatever that will generally go
faster than implementing on top of la if
it doesn't have probably done something
wrong somewhere right there just a price
you pay for it it can be costly to
implement sometimes it's not trivial
doing it
and you need an environment for things
for these things right you need new that
you need the environment the global
state for mutable data what I was
showing whether the example from from
from the world actually that those world
8 right there the actual ones in the
system that's real real stuff but I need
to implement all these I need to handle
this global state pass it around with me
and manage in a nice way I can't get
around that
the final alternative is doing let's see
where are we external systems so it's
good I can access anything there are no
restrictions on what I talk to I just as
long as I get the interface working
correctly so the other other the other
system talks the right way without like
I can talk to anything pick a language I
can talk to it I can monitor and manage
systems and it gives me of course the
maximum efficiency of that system
because I'm using the external the
default implementation of it
I'm just communicating with it then it's
slightly generally interface is a bit
slower even if I'm doing an if in this
case of having a new for a port even
than if it there is data conversion
going backwards and forwards in between
so I'm calling with our line data
structures which I'll then have C code
which accesses and when the C codes
gonna return something it'll build a new
a line data structure for it so it's
slightly slow and it can either be safe
or unsafe so if I am talking with
another node through a port then from
the Aling point of view that's safe
because if that other system dies it
will not crash the ailing system the
worst oil seeds are the ports closed if
I'm using NIF's it is decidedly unsafe
so if something goes wrong in that C
code or whatever the C code calls it
will crash the Alain system again this
is just a trade off I have to make to
choose which one do I want try so I can
get a safe system but I pay for it by
having Sailor slow communication
interaction times I can do a faster
connection one then I'll pay for it by
being unsafe there's not much you gain
you have to make your choice here
it's valuable works and yeah what I want
to end up finally is so a little bit
about how long has one problem right
it's actually used quite a lot but you
don't see it so if you ask people if
they have ever used Allen they'll say no
and but there are core for a lot of
systems in the world which I used are
implemented in Erlang right we're not
talking just that's in the back
companies well I mean whatsapp is your
classic one the whole back-end system of
whatsapp the service is written in Ellen
and they have what over a billion users
now that's an awful lot of a line being
used on for and of course no users no
just this is just their right and
they're not there because it just
happens to be there
there are also classic users of many of
the features of our they literally have
our line systems running running
millions of processors running a
millions of a long process on one system
or one machine and they just do that in
the production system for there are
other uses as well - I mean well
Ericsson of course has some products
written in Allen so if you're sending
mobile data from from your mug from your
phone and you most likely running
through in systems written in Allen
there's some of the base station parts
are written out and I think Ericsson
have somewhere around about 40 percent
of the world market for that so the
chance is very great using Allen even if
what you're doing here today bet365 part
of their system is howling as well so
they did a number of experiments four or
five years ago that we're going to add a
new feature and they do experiments with
hour-long and they like that layout of
that feature you know and then they've
extended that with a few other features
as well written in our so again you
don't see it but it's there and for
those who don't know Beck bit say they
are the largest online betting system in
the world I can never remember if it's
the number of users or the amount of
money but it says there's somewhere for
it so there are serious users of Allen a
few others if you're going here cubic
for example they're the ones who do
quick check the quick check search
systems written in our course it can
check other languages as well
but the basic system is written in our
look for and again as a quick check user
you don't really have to know this it's
there but it just works right what else
Cisco they use our lang and their
switches so you're probably running out
on your many different cases for you
never see it it's just infrastructure
there's also some software that uses it
as well to I mean a classic one is
RabbitMQ RabbitMQ is written in ellen
and most users of rabbitmq never see
this because you don't have to see it
it's there if you need it but doing it I
don't know how many RabbitMQ systems
around the world they're quite a few
where are we yeah caps need caps DB it
was written in a line again you don't
need to know it but it is the react
database which I'd know if you've seen
it but that's also written a line the
company basho they developed that they
went under but now was taken over by
bet365 and they maintain and support
because they're using it themselves
right and what else well yeah I mean the
kallana client about online banking
system the system they use in Europe is
written in a like to have anymore
well they're vulgar games VMware I think
they support rabbitmq we have water
which is a German gaming online gaming
company and part of some of their games
are written in elegant they found when
they went did this they did some tests I
think they've got a tip out of ten times
speed up of the system when converting
from Ruby at least so our line is a lot
of different places you just never see
it which is very nice but it also means
if you ask people they said why should I
learn Ellen because I'll never use it
well they do Alex here has all is also
spreading quite a lot and mostly in a
different world at the moment then for
example some of the standard packages
that come with Alexia are for doing web
servers so quite a lot of web servers
are being used written in Alexia as a
migration say Ruby on Rails using Alex
you in Phoenix they're also extending
into other type of applications as well
so they're also expanding for
there's a lot of airline going on in the
world and that is basically where I want
to end and I'm on time as well two
questions ya know there are two things
you can say the question was can you
upgrade the beam and the rowing system
and that no there are two things you
cannot upgrade to be upgrade one the
running system one is the operating
system and the others have been
unfortunately everything else you can
upgrade but not that honestly oh yeah
yeah okay yes yes but you cannot upgrade
one machine if you're running a single
system you can you want to upgrade the
beam then you have to take it down if
you're running I say multiple modes
multiple machines then of course you can
do rolling upgrades it means you have to
design your system in such a way can
handle them then you also get the
feature that one of the nodes one of
this is one of the machines crashes
everything else just keep on going and
take over the work which you want to do
anyway right but then I'll do that yes
any more more questions nope I want to
show one thing I want to show this
excuse me here I can't help it so what
we've got here and we'll start this up I
think we will run it like this let's see
if this works shall we no display
preferences and if we now do arrangement
we murder this place sorry for it and we
can shut that down and we do this and so
what I'm going to do now is run a little
demo both to show a bit about the
concurrency and some of the
introspection systems as well too
so I am running a spaceship system here
so I'm going to start off and I will
start the system which I try and
increase increase this size yes
like this visible yeah so I'm gonna run
in space which is 500 by 500 vegan I'm
gonna run two thousand ships on them so
I've started up the space here we're not
running it's running but we're not
kicking any clocks so we'll start the
run and I will tick a clock every 75
milliseconds so now we have this to
2,000 ships running okay each ship is a
separate island process so if I look at
this system I'll find that over 2,000
processes running which from the outline
point of view is pretty trivial so we
can look at that let's have a look so I
can I can do I can start an outline here
and I'll call this observer and I will
set the cookie right ship demo like this
and now I will start observer observer
is a tool that comes with a standard
hour lang release it provides in to
provide some some levels of
introspection come up eventually yes
there we go and so what I'm doing now is
I'm running observer on one our line
node and the simulator on another
outline node so we're just showing
distributions as well here so I can tell
which node I want to observe and I want
to observe the simulator so now I'm
looking at the simulator node here and
we can see down here for example I'm
running 2049 processes so each ship is
to each chip is one process and the 49
other processes around I can look at
load charts for example take at a time
get going and now we can see if we look
down here it's bit hard to see it
properly there are eight schedulers one
per core so we're running a jeweler's
the loads distributed and all that and
the load balancers automatic for it I
don't have to do anything about this we
can look at the memory usage we can look
at other things as well we can look at
the memory allocators and I will freely
admit I don't understand what these are
doing but someone who knows about it can
very well to save is the memory is the
memory handling working as it should be
handling right I can look at these
things for I can look internally in the
system I can look at some applications
what not going for it but can look at
low charts here
and and so I'm running the system here
and I can of course do things so I'm
running there I'm just having that I
just have one shell I could start up
multiple shells I can do things so I can
change the programming of the ships so
the ships are actually encode the logic
of the ship is law so so each ship is
running lower code for the logic author
and the logic here is very simple this
stuff it ship just runs in a straight
line until it gets the edge of the
universe and it balances right so it's
very logic like change the logic so I
can say I want to make it a run ship and
I will make the first 1000 of them run
ships so what I'll do now is I'll load
in and recompile the code and you'll
find the run ships agree yeah no it
didn't stop of course didn't stop right
there would be fatal
so now we're running different logic
here for it and if I look if I look at
the load charts here I can see that
there was a bump when of recompiling
loading in the new code a bit where more
memory they're just running right and of
course this is a game and I've all
gained in real games of course you kill
things right so well yeah fine for me
gaming is computer games not not betting
okay it's obvious trick to you so let's
let's make some ships attack ships right
and we'll make a lot of them are so
we'll kill it off quickly
so I'll set I'll make 200 attack ships
now we'll see they will turn orange if
you look there and you'll see the little
little things going that's explosions so
one attack ship does is when it gets
which is normal another ship in front of
it it kills it and I don't have sound so
I'm writing out the sound therefore do
in this space we hear things as you go
boom boom boom boom boom but I don't
have sound for it and now we see the
ships are going down of course now if I
look at the load I see the loads
dropping of course because they're less
processes less memory usage to
everything I can see this it's keeping
pretty earth balanced now we can do some
fun things this this one I like so we
have this concept of schedulers and each
schedule is running one one operating
system thread and they're balanced for
it I can shut down
so I can do a line call on system flag
I've got that right yes shed weight
shared euler's online so I don't want to
run each schedulers anymore let's go
down to four shall we so I'll set it to
4 here and we're now what will happen
now is I've shut down four schedulers
and it's moving the process and from
those four across the other ones so now
it's now it's only working on four
schedulers we're running into a bit of
problem here well not a problem actually
what's happening here is the a line
system and not only load balances but if
it decides we have so little load will
actually try and shut schedulers down by
itself that's why we're seeing some of
them dropping but I'm moving things
across here as well so I can set it back
to eight I can set it to where specific
to and see if we can see then anymore
here for
footman's yeah that's sorry yes that's
why it's going all weird sorry
now we can sit down and now we see it
shut down we shut down six of them
depressed running on - sorry that was me
misspelling it doesn't try it
automatically correct but yeah I do that
so yeah I can I can control a lot of
things in the system while the system is
running for I just want to show one
thing and then we're done
so I mentioned but we'll kill this and I
will restart it again and we'll just
start no down yes that that's that's the
that's the observer saying the nodes
gone down that's okay we went but we
won't worry about that
so will you start here we'll start 500
mm again so I was mentioning before an
example of why you should definitely not
do synchronous communication in parallel
systems so all these ships if we start
them start the run here they're just
running independently they're not
looking around it'd be very nice to have
a ship that for example have a flock of
ships so if they find other ships around
them they could follow it and do things
like this for so we do have a flock ship
here so I can set ships again to flock
ship and we'll set the whole lot for and
they all become flock ships here and now
they're becoming well they're orange and
when they're finding flocks they're
becoming green and yeah something's
going wrong right and it took us about
less than one minute the whole system to
hang the reason of course for this is is
that we're doing synchronous
communication they'll discover a ship
close and they're sent off a synchronous
request saying where are you and how
fast you're going and then sit and wait
for the reply and the whole system
blocked in less than a minute so a very
clear example I should be very careful
doing synchronous communication in
parallel systems and I cannot restart
them anymore because they did they're
just hung like they're just sitting
there hanging so yeah that's me
okay and for any more questions for most
likely over time
okay thank you the presentation coming
afterwards now will look more a long and
actually described at a higher level
using at doing things with it and
examples of doing things with it not at
the level I've been talking about or
what might exist for that could be that
that is also interesting see it actually
in actual use and real systems in actual
use
[Music]